[Musik]
halt deine fresse leute es ist
wunderschönes wetter und ich werde
gleich den ganzen tag interesse sein
aber es ist die gamescom also ist
eigentlich ganz cool macht eben nicht
mehr in einem live zu sehen sein
wir werden damit ein brief veranstalten
ich habe pressetermin obwohl ich werde
heute einen live wie mir den senioren
und socken macht also wenn ihr das video
gesehen weil er schon mit iris carlo
leute die sich freuen uns mit seiner
erfahrung richtig viele ich ihm alles
bedeutet sind ist das nicht das heißt es
passiert endlich vorüber als im vorjahr
gegenüber halt eine scheiß presse handy
bevor ich hatte irgendwas an diesem
wunderschönen sonnigen tag machen werde
mache ich mir jetzt erst mal weg ist
ich habe gerade einfach drei stunden auf
dem block geschnitten habe ich jetzt
gerade noch hochgeladen und jetzt fahre
ich zur gamescom
hey ich habe den termin jetzt auf der
bühne es ist gerade 71
vollkommen beschwert man sich beschweren
kann ich mich da normalerweise
da
er wird man instagram pushen ihnen gerne
sagen wir den namen laserdrucker
schillig alle abonnieren press gerade
auf dieser bühne hier oben haben sie ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen und man kann der
schnelle an felix der lassen
auf jeden fall jetzt um die gaming
standbilder die senioren treffen
mit dem livestream machen
wir machen wir zusammen ein video das
ein live
wir sind davon ist die beste aus von
unserem live stream also die rechte hand
dem auslassen
damit kannst dich halten
sein kopf sei er gewesen
du musst jetzt war sie als channel genau
das wollen genau genau mit der maus cast
der serie wohin mit den augen jetzt hast
du schon als sechs blöcke und jetzt muss
das team noch mal wieder rauskommen ja
das weiß ich dass wir für die mannschaft
dass spieler die auch schon auf dem
kanal gespielt
das ist stimmt und da vorne wenn du mal
dahin schaut er voraus andere richtung
und da wurde da in den baum
das wasser hier vertreten wird jetzt
muss die leertaste gedrückt hat schaut
beispielsweise war noch eine bude genau
jetzt geben wir mit jeder ein bisschen
auf wurde
jetzt kannst du dich mit der linken
maustaste den betriebs kannst du mir
jetzt hat bach und andere genau so und
jetzt nach oben gucken
das ist der baum jetzt kaufen die linke
weiter zurück
dass es wichtig ist mit der rechten
faust und genau das ist schon fast das
was wir gerade gebaut
so ähnlich ist so herrlich der hand mehr
oder weniger hilflos dass der klub das
hier dieses große das ist die linke
genau das war schwer genau wo das ist
schlecht das glaubt auch nach hinten
oder zur seite genau laufen und laufen
ja genau wider
aber das blatt wieder wenden das ballett
ist ein kauf die gerade genau jetzt bist
du aufgehört und jetzt wusste zu einer
freien fläche
wir haben tatsächlich das geschafft was
bisher hier denn in zwei tagen rund um
die uhr getroffen niemand geschafft hat
der blick
herzlichen glückwunsch trotzdem pc
kümmern und die evelyn bisschen bergauf
geht und ich dachte okay sollte einfach
mehr druck und dann rum laufen dann
kommt die tastatur wie drückt die ganze
entweder das passiert recht häufig ihr
auto begann alles richtig und alles ist
einfach stehen geblieben eine komplette
suite ist gerade da ist hat im travel
ich habe jetzt gerade mit den senioren
sollten gesorgt wer jetzt gedacht dass
gerade leichter vorne läuft es schrieben
sogar noch hinten gerade und ich gehe es
auf jeden fall erstmal nicht dass es im
verein sache schleifen wir von jana und
die stillen gta und ich bewerte jetzt
mit servierten
ich weiß wir bei youtube definitiv
neuesten gesetzt der mit lässt ob
hintergrund ist corny und kran die
können wir das nach jahrzehnten kaputt
die mittel
wie eine stunde überzogen aber jetzt ist
endlich alles leer
diese jetzt zurückkommt kommen stehen
sie baten den man mit keiner muss
aufpassen dass man gar nicht gegenteil
richtig krank macht oder so ich habe
meine brille im taxi vergessen ich habe
ja doch mal anrufen der meinte dass
erdöl aus platz mit genommen also dahin
gehen dass alles cool die sache ist
jetzt nur dass meine eltern bereits
geschrieben hatten wir werden laufen
letzten block noch dass das meine
terrasse hat und angebracht werden muss
also zu ende gebracht werden muss das
passiert jetzt morgen um 8 uhr 30 und
ich jetzt auf dem ams und danach wegen
doch auf der youtube partie
das heißt ich werde c&a zehn minuten
bleibt gefühlt also mein outfit weiße
socken die sieht man eh nicht so eine
blau graue hose dann haben wir weiße
zloty dort die kamera ist ja voll schief
um meine haare sind auch noch nicht
wieso mache ich laufe da und da werde
ich noch gar nicht fertig kündigte jetzt
auf jeden fall noch zu einem schönen
abendessen mit studio 71 danach youtube
partie werde allerdings um ein handy
mitnehmen das heißt ja jetzt kommen
handyaufnahmen
[Musik]
wir laufen jetzt gerade von der youtube
hat die zurückholen uns jetzt ein taxi
und ja noch nicht haben einfach nichts
getroffen und gefühlte trotzdem als
label bedruckt weil wir da ganz oben
waren und jetzt so vollmundig und wir
sehen dass die fahrt wieder zurück zu
hause angekommen ich bin irgendwie total
einfach ich glaube gegen den ganzen tag
games kommen und so weiter und so fort
jetzt der partie aber mega coole leute
getroffen morgen geht's auf die video
lab ist da
[Musik]
video das die sache ist dann zuerst mal
ganz kurz ein instagram passion für
meinen blog
wie heißt du da laser luca ok chilliger
anderem ein paar tv sender paar videos
bei mir benutzen wollen und wie läuft
hatte hier unter der schautag also keine
autogrammstunde nach weißensee ist wenn
wir sind gerade wieder handwerker oben
wegen der terrasse
deswegen mache ich mir 62 aber ich werde
die kamera ist nicht mit dem was wir
sehen uns jetzt claudia ich bin jetzt
völlig mit essen und fahre jetzt und den
video days mit er und jana über viele
staffeln weg bei der night king
[Musik]
aber sie haben dann keinen kranken höher
ist das beste an der jugendliche ist nur
das essen einfach nur komplizierter als
nur konkretes kulisse
sie muss ich dann bei 4 videos nicht
eingebracht habe ich mühe jannik 12 in
meiner klasse geben die jungs mit ihren
mega stelzen haben die leiden ich hoffe
dann sagen wir aus dem vollen klein
alle werden
wir sind durch wieder im himmel auf
erden angekommen
was hältst du von block oder instagram
im block burschen laser luca laser laser
laser luca beschädigt ich bin wieder bei
mir zu hause angekommen
deswegen für sich hier in meinem
aufnahmen zimmer und werde jetzt erstmal
diesen blog hier schneiden es ist jetzt
gerade sechs das heißt ich werde ja zwei
stunden an dem video hier schneiden und
dann sehen wir uns in zwei stunden
wieder ein paar freunde rumkommen
es stinkt beiden alona gutachten geht es
hier auch gut was dein lieblings
zwischen kanal kahn kratzer und jetzt
als allerletztes darf dann insta pushen
laser lukasz szukala abonnieren wir
gehen jetzt zur university das heißt
wenn jetzt auch noch werden mit dem
iphone sein handy von apple
[Musik]
a
ich bin jetzt wieder zu hause angekommen
es ist gerade halb vier ich wo ich
eigentlich gar nicht so lange da bleiben
aber es waren erfolgte freunde da
nachher war noch da die mit ihrem freund
felix waren noch daten auf aufgelegte
alles mega sich aber ich bin jetzt auch
und gemüse und ich muss halt morgen
autogrammstunde geben also die geht nach
stunden los und ich morgen früh noch
diesen blog hier schneiden wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon mitbekommen haben
sind bei mir derzeit immer sehr viele
handwerker hier am start weil wir ein
bisschen was verändern müssen an der
terrasse und deswegen muss ich
eigentlich besser reden habe meine
eltern nebenan schlafen heut morgen
wieder um 38 eben deswegen kriege ich
jetzt auf ganz entspanntes viereinhalb
stunden schlaf beschwerden kann ich mich
da normalerweise eher weniger an der
stelle würde ich jetzt noch gar nicht
weiter lang rum reden wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat würde ich mich
sehr über andauern hoch freuen ihr könnt
unter dem video auch abonieren klicken
da seid ihr neuer abonnent von einem
kanal und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf diese glocke hier klicken
und dann kommt die benachrichtigung
sobald ich ein neues video hochladen und
ich weiß normalerweise stelle ich meine
kämpfe vor die tür aber diesmal möchte
dass ich machen weil das der flur ist
und meine eltern schlafen nebenan
deswegen wir sehen uns übermorgen im
neuen blog von 1
ich habe euch lieb vielleicht alt an
luxus von leicht aus
[Musik]